foreign
[Music]
most of us have a memory of being asked
what do you want to be when you grow up
we're often brought up with this notion
that we have to choose one precise thing
to excel at and if we don't know well
it's okay we'll find out in time in
Western culture it's very common to be
defined by that one thing which is our
day job so it's no wonder why we put a
lot of emphasis on this
but what if we can't choose just one
thing growing up I wanted to be a writer
a singer a film director editor a game
developer an artist and even a vet at
one point and even up until this day I
still see myself as a mixture of all of
these things apart from a vet because I
never actually went went down that road
and if this sounds relatable to you then
you have clicked on the Right video
because we are going to be talking about
having multiple passions how to manage
these how to make money from these and
if it's even possible firstly I'd like
you to ask yourself
why do you have these multiple Passions
is it because you have an intrinsic
desire to learn these multiple different
types of things because it makes you
feel fulfilled in your life or are you
doing it for someone else are you trying
to please others by making time for a
skill or a possible career that's
perhaps will make them proud of you or
happy for you but at the same time
you're trying to fit in time to do
things that make yourself happy for a
long time I try to choose between films
games and music and I found myself
becoming a videographer but also needing
to make a game alongside that and now
that I'm a game designer I still make
these YouTube videos because I don't
want to give up film
and throughout that whole time I've been
making music I've lost counter the
amount of times that I've been advised
to choose one and stick with it but I've
learned over the years that this would
lead to me feeling pretty unfulfilled
and if you can relate to this then this
video should be able to hopefully help
you or give you some insight today
however if you feel a little bit
differently and perhaps you're trying to
cram too much in for different reasons
then maybe you need a little bit more
introspection so I received this email
that I think you might find relatable
it's from someone called Matt and they
say I'm writing to you because I'm
seeking some advice I've recently got
rejected by what seemed like a promising
opportunity at blank as an associate
game designer after about seven
interviews it was really heartbreaking
because to work at that company is a
dream job for me that being said now I'm
going back into job searching mode as I
naively was banking on getting an offer
since it seems so promising similar to
you I have passions in both game
development and music so part of this
new time for me is trying to find how I
could Mel those two passions together my
big question to you is do you have any
advice on how to mail these two Fields
I've seen how you do music videos in
Unreal Engine any advice you have on how
to make an income from melding these two
Fields often whatever I'm creating
whether it be personal projects in-game
development or music production I get
bogged down by the thought that I'm not
actively making money while creating the
thoughts that I'm wasting my time when I
could be applying to a job that would
make me money any and all input is
appreciated just going through an
interesting transition point in life and
seeking Clarity so I thought that was a
very well put email I get a lot of
emails similar to this so I felt like
answering it in a video form could help
more than just you Matt but hello Matt
and thank you for the email so Matt is
feeling unsure about where to go in
their career after receiving a rejection
protections suck we've all been in there
I have certainly been there and I think
it's really awesome that you're already
thinking okay what's my next step and is
this even a direction that I should be
going in right now
Matt is seeking to unionize their
passions which I think is something that
maybe a lot of people have questions
about so I'll do my best today to talk
through how I manage being a game
designer a YouTuber and a musician and
also a little bit of a writer on the
side but most of you don't even realize
I do that so firstly how do I do it all
how do you do it all how does anyone do
at all planning I would get absolutely
nowhere without planning I do weekly
monthly and yearly goals so I'm often
checking in with myself and where I want
to be which I find very useful
especially when you have a lot of
passions and therefore you can get
distracted pretty easily I also like to
color code these goals so that I can
easily visualize what I am spending most
of my time on is it on game development
is it on YouTube is it on music and then
once I've written down these goals it's
pretty easy for me to also visualize
what goals could work nicely together
so for instance it actually took me a
long time of just creating music videos
as in with a camera and myself and my
guitar to then get the idea of oh I
could actually make music videos in game
engines and this allowed me to meld both
my game development skills and my music
skills together so I could be building
upon these skills within one personal
project this is the type of synergy
you'll be striving for because as you
probably already know if you have a lot
of hobbies there's not enough time in
the day for you to be spending on all of
those Hobbies so it's very easy to end
up spreading yourself out too thin and
then burning out so if you could do
multiple hobbies in one project then
that's the best of both worlds right
some examples I can think of off the top
of my head is if you're interested in
architecture and game development then
you might want to do a piece of level
design
and if you are a writer and an artist
and you also love music maybe you could
do a graphic novel with its own
soundtrack that goes along with it every
week I will sit down on a Sunday and
work out my next week in my calendar so
I can actually block everything out and
make sure I have time for everything
that I wanted to do through my weekly
goals by doing this you're allowing
yourself to focus on the goals that you
want to achieve but I know you you
probably get ideas all the time if you
have a lot of hobbies so do feel free to
write those ideas down somewhere whether
that is or notes on your phone through a
journal Google keep Discord even this
means that you don't feel like those
ideas are a waste they're still being
kept there somewhere for the future if
you want to see more about how I set
goals you can join me every Monday
morning at 7 00 a.m where I start a
Monday morning motivation stream and we
talk about our weekly goals and I show
you how I set out mine prioritize so
planning also helps you to visualize if
you are spreading yourself out too thin
which for a lot of us is quite a lot of
the time
and sometimes yes even though it's
difficult you do have to put one passion
to three passions aside for some time
but just know that even if you're having
to push something aside you have your
whole life to come back to them I used
to love art I used to adore painting but
I simply don't have the time to do that
anymore so I might Doodle for myself
every now and then but really I'm
pushing it aside for now so I can spend
time on the passions that pay my rent
and that are also just more beneficial
to me in this point in my life I've even
had to go down to working part-time in
my main job as a game designer so that I
can actually have more time to spend on
my other passions so I can feel happier
Within Myself And if you have that
choice for you then I think it's a
brilliant way to go sometimes you just
need to ask you never know what you
might get from that trust in the process
this is something that I need to remind
myself of often and therefore maybe you
need to hear it as well
you do not need to get everything done
today tomorrow next week even this year
or next year you have more time than you
realize
and just because you haven't chosen your
career Hill to die on
if that makes sense like you haven't
Chosen One finite career path or skill
does not mean that you are hindering any
part of your future careers there is
nothing wrong with you
J.R.R Tolkien would never have started
to write the Lord of the Rings at age 45
if he had not studied language for as
long as he did because that was his
passion written poetry because that was
also his passion and experienced Life by
even going to World War One not saying
you need to go to war but I'm just
saying you do also need to live and have
life experiences hideo Kojima would
never have created a whole new video
game genre through metal gear solid if
he hadn't had a passion in film before
he entered the games industry we are
human beings and we are fluid It's
Perfectly Normal to adapt and change
perhaps in 10 20 30 years time your
passions might be completely different
to what they are right now it doesn't
mean that what you're doing now might
not help your future self in whatever
you want to achieve then how to make
money
so this is the big question that I get
asked all the time and I'm just going to
be upfront and honest with you here and
tell you the way that I make money
through creating Game Dev art and music
is actually by having a job before I was
a game designer in AAA I was a
videographer in the education space
before that I worked in catering during
University and before that I was a web
developer in advertising and before that
I worked in retail so many shitty retail
stores yeah this is how I've made my
money YouTube has opened so many doors
for me but I'm not gonna sugarcoat it
it's difficult to make money on this
platform unless you are raking in the
views which a lot of us don't you won't
see much of an income here and that
that's me included so I'm not I'm not
just digging on you
but what it has afforded me is the
opportunity to create a portfolio that
has really helped me get my main paying
current role that I'm working in now and
actually even my videographer role was
mainly because of my YouTube channel
because they found it but it's also
allowed other creative people to easily
find me and reach out to me about doing
voice-overs or music or helping on dev
projects that they're doing and sure
sometimes it can be a paid gig but more
often than not it's just a passion
project that I feel I would really like
to get involved in I guess the question
you need to ask yourself is what is your
passion and is that money which is
completely valid I actually know people
who have been in Creative Industries
such as someone was in the music
industry and then they changed
Industries and they no longer play music
because they don't get paid for it
anymore or
is your passion just there because you
really enjoy doing the thing and if it's
the former then yeah you will want to be
making something for money because if
making it just for the sake of making it
doesn't make you happy then why would
you but if it's the latter and you find
fulfillment in the simple process of
creating the thing
then the only thing that makes your work
worthwhile is how it makes you and
others feel I got pretty down on myself
quite a few years ago because I was at
an event an indie game event actually
with my DSLR camera and a businessman
walks up to me and he says how good are
you at your craft and I was a bit taken
aback and I said why I don't know I
think I'm okay I guess you know in a
humble sort of way and he replied to me
well just look at your bank account and
that will tell you how good you are
I was a student at the time so my bank
was pretty much dry and it stuck with me
for a couple of years where I just
thought I'm not making much money
therefore I must be terrible at what I'm
doing but now quite a few years later I
have realized that money does not equate
the worth
of a project or a thing that I have
spent my time creating
I create because I enjoy creating and I
can't quite pinpoint exactly why but I
do know that whenever I get feedback
about my indie game Perfection or any of
my music for instance and people tell me
how it connected with them on an
emotional level
that means so much more to me than
learning how much money these projects
have made and putting pressure on
yourself
to make loads of money or have it be
really popular this that or the other it
actually takes the fun out of creating
whatever it is you want to create and
kind of negates the point about why you
wanted to create in the first place
although saying that I am aware that
it's a privilege to be in the position
where you don't necessarily have to make
money because you're making money by
other means and you have some free time
to make something for yourself
essentially but if you do have that
privilege then I would say really take
advantage of that and just create for
creation's sake if you can just remember
always be mindful of what you're
spending your time on and why that's not
to say you can't have down time you need
to be working all the time that's not
what I'm trying to say here I'm trying
to say that what you are working on be
mindful of is it for you is it
fulfilling you what do you want to get
out of it so
all of that
even worse pursuing multiple passions
ultimately I think being a
multi-passionate person can be a really
rewarding way of life
because I found that I mix in with a
bunch of different types of people and I
also get to experience many different
types of work and Fields of Interest so
therefore it's it's really difficult to
become bored because there's a lot of
things going on all the time
however with that being said it can also
be really difficult to to manage
everything all at once and to keep on
track of everything and make sure that
I'm not splitting myself out too thin
I'm getting burnt out I've also found
through the years that you have to be
very sure of yourself as a person
there were quite a few years where I
doubted myself and I thought that I
would be a better person just a better
human being if I could just focus on one
subject and a lot of people told me that
a lot of people told me to do that they
say Jack of all trades and master of
none and that's true to an extent
I know that I'll never be the best
guitarist singer game developer writer
um what else do I do
YouTuber video editor all these things
because I'm not dedicating all of my
time to that one specific skill I'm
spreading it out
um throughout all of them
this kind of made me question myself for
quite a few years and and got me down
um because I thought I'd never be good
at anything I'd just be okay and a lot
of things however as I've come to
embrace myself being a multi-passionate
individual and not being able to change
my stubborn self I've realized that my
knowledge uh and all of these things
combined actually makes me quite a
unique asset and it allows me to do
things like make music videos in annual
engine which a lot of people aren't
doing and that's just because I do have
this interest in multiple different
things and I was able to see the lines
between them and um
synergize essentially only you can
decide what you want to do with the time
you have on this planet
and I think a lot of us worry way too
much about being successful or good
enough or making enough money and making
others proud of us
and
really
we should just follow what feels right
within us
and if that isn't following one thing
that we have found and that we think
represents us and that we want to be our
whole lives
that's okay so yeah I think that's the
best answer I can give in the most
roundabout way of course I can't tell
you exactly what to do with your lives
and I'm sorry if it wasn't specific
enough for you Matt but I hope that you
can take something away from my Rambles
and what I've learned through my journey
really it's okay to have a main paying
job in one of your passions and to just
find some time to do the others on the
side while you're getting some money and
some experience that's absolutely fine
and if you want to try and synergize
your passions that's awesome too that
you'll probably have to end up being a
freelance if you do want to do something
very unique like that and the only way
you're going to get freelance work is if
you start creating and you put it out
there and people can actually see what
you can do and it's not wasted time
because you'll be building up your
skills and and building yourself a
portfolio and hopefully having some
inner fulfillment along the way
okay that is all the advice that I can
give for you today and I feel like doing
ballet for some weird reason so this is
a little bit of a different video for
you I wanted to do something a little
bit quicker because I have another Game
Dev Unreal Engine tutorial coming up and
it's taking a little bit longer than I
thought
but I have a goal this year of putting
out a video once a month so let's see
how I do this
if you have a experience you'd like to
share about having multiple passions if
you have any questions that you'd like
to ask that this video has not addressed
please put them down in the chat I would
love to see them I'll try to respond to
as many as possible also I want to say a
massive thank you to my patreons who
really helped me to keep this content
going as I mentioned I did go part-time
so they really mean a lot to me
especially now and I know they say this
on every video but I stream on Twitch uh
quite often I've gone up to three
streams a week now and I am going to be
playing indie games made by small teams
of developers or even solo developers so
if you're interested in that follow me
at twitch.tv slash yagmax
so hope to see you more this year thanks
for sticking around and watching my
videos always much appreciated and Matt
best of luck for the future
okay have a lovely day evening bye
[Music]
[Applause]